just when I thought we were going to
have a drama-free end to the year for CS
go we got hit with one of the most
insane debates I've seen in some time is
shroud better than simple this is what
I'll say that trout could do in CS
simple can never do
that's what I'll say yep Freakazoid has
once again found himself in the hot seat
after claiming that shroud is better
than simple is there any validity to
that claim or was it just bait and is
shroud's response arrogance or are
people reading into it too much let's
find it all out and put this thing to
rest
[Music]
already folks before we get into it I
wanted to remind you all again that we
now got merch it is sexy beautiful
unique good quality I think you guys
would all love it we got our touchgrass
hoodie our classic Esports crewnecks and
so much more so if you're interested
head into the description and follow the
link to our store and maybe pick up some
stuff all right before we dive into this
mess allow me to set the stage shroud is
an absolutely massive twitch streamer
Who moonlights as a valorin pro and he
is widely known for being a monster at
almost every game he picks up
thank you
I hope I didn't take any kills there
dude there's so many people next to his
undeniable FPS Talent shroud also played
CS go professionally but hung his hat up
back in 2017. simple on the other hand
is the opping star of Navi a major
winner and player of the decade
nasty stuff
get himself
is something special so if simple might
be CS Go's greatest of all time how the
hell did we get to this debate well last
week CS Go Pro turns streamer Freakazoid
was streaming with his brother and some
other Usual Suspects for those that
don't know who freak is he was most
famously a part of the 2015 Cloud9
roster he now spends his time getting
absolutely yoked while streaming CS go
and ballerin anyway the group was
watching a pro match while reminiscing
about nacs when freak said this I'm
telling you the I've seen shroud do
is shroud is just like police he just
watched it like you would never In that
clip of him in Battlefield this is what
uh this is what I'll say the that
trout could do in CS simple can never do
an edited version of that clip was then
posted to Twitter days later and a few
people in the community went insane some
seem to agree with freak at least
ironically but the majority of the
replies were just Clowning on him freak
later replied to the Tweet himself
claiming that the clip was taken out of
context so being the astute reporter
that I am I went back and checked to see
what the entire conversation was really
about it started with the boys
discussing who the best and an ACS go
player was of all time names like Stu
Elise and twists were thrown around
until they got onto the topic of who the
best player was skill wise that's when
freak mentioned shroud
skill then okay none of you guys played
another team of them she weren't graced
to be able to watch this he and way
better skilled than everybody in that
you guys just mentioned
by far free continued to wax nostalgic
about shroud in the 2015 Glory Days
until they somehow got to the topic of
simple and what role he would take if
modesty ever came back to Navi later in
a reply to his chat freak implied that
shroud was a better rifler than simple
that is when we get to the clip that has
since gone viral so the context I think
freak was referring to is the fact that
he was specifically talking about
Trout's ability with a rifle and he
thinks that was missing from the edited
clip regardless I'm not too surprised
about this take from Freak he played
with shroud during this time and he also
has a lot of respect for the na guys he
came up with on top of that freak has
historically never shied away from
giving his thoughts on simple with all
that being said I don't think freak
meant to do any harm with his comment
this was just the memories he had of his
former teammate and opponent back in
2015. as it stands simple has endless
accolades including like I said player
of the decade and he is better in almost
every aspect on top of that shroud only
played at the top level for a few years
and although he's an undeniably talented
gamer he's considered by some people out
there to be pretty overrated when it
comes to CS go now could you make the
argument that back in 2015 shroud had
more mechanical skill with the rifle
than simple sure would I care to find
out even if it was possible probably not
nevertheless this was just a harmless
argument and the online Discord should
have ended with the memes but this is
the internet after all and honestly it
probably would have ended there if
shroud himself didn't end up replying to
the Tweet saying this a lot of it comes
down to Passion I'll never be as
passionate as simple therefore I'll
never even come close to the talent he
has in my opinion now this seems like a
harmless respectful way of giving praise
to a fellow player right
well no apparently not everyone took it
that way don't get me wrong tons of
people saw it as a classy response but a
few out there thought it was a bit of a
cop-out from shroud CS go broadcaster
Maui snake took offense in particular
replying the hilarious reach here is
that shroud implies he is more naturally
talented than simple given that a lot of
it comes down to Passion Maui continued
to double down and while I do understand
how shroud's tweet can be interpreted
this way I don't think that it should be
I think shroud was simply trying to make
it clear that there was no debate listen
I don't know shrub personally and I'm
not his PR guy but he just doesn't
strike me like the type of person that
would use the I could have been the best
I just didn't feel like a card even
though it may have read like that to
some people but then again that's also
just my take and this whole debate has
revolved around people's different
interpretations about what's been said
but I do think Maui's tweet brought up
an interesting conversation one about
natural talent I think suggesting that
simple is only as good as he is due to
some unquantifiable natural Talent
downplays The Blood Sweat and Tears he's
poured into this game now I don't think
anyone who reacted negatively to
shroud's tweet is stupid they understand
how much passion simple has for the game
I just don't think they know how
important that is I think that once you
get to a certain level of competition
like shroud and simple have you start to
appreciate that raw god-given skill
isn't really all that having the
commitment to becoming the greatest in
the world is a remarkable talent in its
own right but just to put a pin in it
shroud is not better than simple at CS
go
he may be in literally every other game
just not this one there are a ton of Cs
go players with cracked aim big brains
and other X factors but simple has it
all plus a once in a generation level of
determination will that stop people from
debating simples greatness in the future
absolutely not this is the internet come
on and see us go
not a chance so since that is the case
and this will happen again
I'll see you on the next one
I do not think that shroud is the most
overrated CS go player of all time I
think that's rude there's people that
see him with rose-colored glasses
obviously but a lot of that is just
people liking to start is he overrated
sure he didn't really play that much he
didn't really win that much but
who really gives a I mean that's
the ultimate answer who gives it
who